tomorrow a nation's eyes and ears turned
to the testimony of fired FBI director
James Comey so come on down to Buffalo
Wild Wings for kill me Thursday doors
open at 4:00 hey the place will be
having the beers will be flowing in the
wings just like the testimony will be
it's Washington Superbowl and we've got
a ton of Comey combos to fill you up
while you take in the hot mouth to mic
action of Intelligence Committee
Chairman Richard Burr the very people
represented man look at him go our
witnesses this morning plus keep track
of Donnie's brain parts twist by tweet
on our courtesy workstations and
two-for-one grass courtesy of Underoath
lager the only leaks will be coming out
of your day yeah pingas pingas pingas
specials include my ties to russia
collusion with Moscow mules impeachment
mojitos our promised no faith booze and
of course wings like the Trump
administration and the majority of the
Senate Intelligence Committee our wings
are a hundred percent white me
Connie will say his patented catchphrase
Florida lordy Lordy lordy Lordy so come
on down to be jobs for Coley
part of that ad that really disturbed me
all right
I think was dingus yes dingus
you